[Music]
an undertaker
not our favorite not not not v um
not our favorite undertaker admits to
selling corpses for cash while telling
relatives that they had been cremated
wow i've heard about this this happens a
bunch how much you think you can make
off selling a body didn't we just talk
about someone selling kidneys or
something like that or that's different
organ sales that that's a right market
this is undercover like i mean
underground cadavers pretty much like
who wants to buy corpses yes
don't buy underground though oh i don't
know i mean maybe it's a poor school
it's a black market body megan hess is
her name the owner of a funeral home in
colorado she is admitted to swiping dead
bodies to resell their harvested heads
spines arms and legs to surgical
training companies oh
good guess like they don't have enough
of them huh i mean if it's for science
do yeah it doesn't matter if uh you know
the family members
imagine being like in like surgeon
school or something like that like going
to work or whatever like aunt karen like
oh [ __ ] that does happen right
i feel like we did one article about
that one time too somebody found out
that their relative passed away because
they were in a class for that and then
saw their uncles like
yeah i feel like we did an article a
long time ago how bad would that [ __ ]
you up that would [ __ ] me up pretty hard
i guess it depends on the relative no
still though like
yeah like arteries and plus they're like
naked and [ __ ] too and like cut open if
it's a couple of my uncles i'd be like
ooh can i have some popcorn please oh
yeah this is okay
some family members are like oh yeah
you son of a [ __ ] so uh megan has owned
the now closed sunset mesa funeral home
in colorado and another business called
donor services through which she sold
the heads spines arms and legs she
entered the guilty plea to a charge of
fraud at a colorado magistrates court
yesterday and will be sentenced in
january prosecution are pushing for her
to spend 12 to 15 years in prison
she is 45 now admitted on tuesday that
through her funeral home she defrauded
at least a dozen families seeking
cremation services for deceased
relatives do you think it would be as
bad as she goes yo so i didn't cremate
your family but
here's 200 bucks which is about 50 50
of what i saw i sold it for 400 bucks so
you get 200 bucks how about that and
they're like thanks or if it's like
here's 200 bucks and here's just a bag
of random ashes yeah
no no it's mixed that's probably what
you did it's a party it's a party mix of
people how'd you get caught well yeah at
least here it says instead of cremating
the bodies court records show her body
broke her company harvested their parts
then sold them mostly for surgical
training other educational purpose has
been scheduled to go on trial in three
weeks along with her mother shirley who
was also previously uh pleaded not
guilty but i guess she wasn't
accomplished something like that
uh
heard change blah blah blah information
information uh after the assistant u.s
attorney jeremy chafin made his
sentencing recommendation the lawyer for
hess urged a lighter sentence of about
two years in prison for this and uh has
been free on bond since her arrest i
guess there's a body shortage out there
huh schools need cadavers dude do you
think this chick's just firing up
duralogs and just
taking that [ __ ] out of there yeah
do you think do you think she's like
firing up the ones that like smell like
kfc
i've lit one of those it actually really
does smell like kfc it really smells
like yeah it smells like the [ __ ] 11
spices
so you just get hungry when you're
roasting marshmallows and [ __ ] for
chicken kind of [ __ ] up because it's
like
it's it's an artificial smell for sure
but it smells like [ __ ] kfc bro
that's why i think we're in a [ __ ]
simulation so they have lemon meringue
pie candles now and it smells exactly
like it those candles are pretty legit
they have cinnamon toast crunch
sprinkles have you seen that
and you can get twix sprinkles so you
could get like uh if you want cinnamon
toast crunch to flavor and like let's
say you bake some sugar cookies or
whatever oatmeal you can get that and
sprinkle it on now where did you find
them how do they lock in these flavors
bro that's what i'm saying they're just
take it they're using their shrink rate
shrinking them down
putting it in a plate that's what it is
it's so smart
yeah shrink rays are cool except for
when you get in there with the fly oh if
it happens to your kids dude that's bad
there's bad news bears right there
that would never happen yeah that's
right yeah
i saw it in a documentary we got to be
careful for that
documentary
in 3d no
no
selling organs such as hearts kidneys
and tendons for transplant is illegal in
the united states but the sale of
cadavers and body parts for use in
research or education which is what hess
did is not regulated by federal law
really oh so few state laws provide any
regulation and almost anyone regardless
of expertise can dissect and sell human
body parts dude it's an open market
letter free dude that's called adam
smith's invisible hand at work
and in the scam one of the family was
given builders concrete instead of their
loved ones ashes builders concrete added
some water to it like
grandma's a rock now that's crazy has
charged families up to one thousand
dollars for cremations that never
occurred that's [ __ ] up i think the
real crime here is she just stole
product yeah she she's she sold stolen
product you know stolen property yes it
did many families received ashes from
bins mixed with the remains of different
cadavers see it's a party mix
where's grandma everywhere
she's spread out and uh the court
documents said that the former employee
accused hess of earning 40 a former
employee accused has earning 40 000 by
extracting and selling the gold teeth of
some of the deceased
that's just a [ __ ] good idea that's a
good yeah that's a good all of this
rings and [ __ ] super [ __ ] up totally
[ __ ] up but like business-wise it's a
great [ __ ] favorite you want to put
all that gold in the ground yeah dude
what else it's considered upcycling
right it's a new thing up cycling that's
a good rebrand i like how they're not
like they're they're trying to do zero
waste you know and they're very like
eco-friendly you know what this reminds
me of is like the hunter gatherers but
then of today and then they they get the
body and then they're just using every
piece making sure that all of it is
respected that's what the native
americans did
exactly it's very spiritual i like it
just put a face to a name
she looks like a sweet all right they're
tammy fay beautiful woman like she's in
charge of my hoa dude she looks like a
wedding crashers character i mean uh
wedding singer characters yeah she looks
like she's out of a movie yeah she looks
like one of those fuzzy like pencil
tough friends
she looks like she works at a diner that
still allows smoking inside let's keep
going what else does she look like
she looks like she stopped by my mom's
door back in the day and sold mary kay
yeah she looks like she works at the
customer service department at walmart
she looks like she doesn't have a job
but reads a newspaper and a hair salon
all day with a thing over her head yeah
yeah true that's her job
she's just there in the background of
all the movies yeah she doesn't have a
real life she's just there she
auditioned for roseanne didn't make the
part damn really that's so sad that's
kind of [ __ ] real that's real that's
kind of [ __ ] up it doesn't really make
any sense because it was roseanne's show
yeah yes there was a reason why she
didn't get it because is your name
roseanne no oh there you go so
roseanne's doing a stand-up you know a
show about her stand-up and then they're
like you still need to audition
do they give her they give her notes on
her audition
we think you're going to get it
we have to do it yeah
so you guys don't like the rose down
when that's nah that was whack those
waxes what's kind of [ __ ] up
there's one more you're actually in
front of me one more she's coming with
one more what does she look like she
looks like she vacations to las vegas
but goes to fremont street only
that sounds like a good time though she
looks like she just she's she just told
all her neighbors to come over and check
out her backyard because she has a deck
with a [ __ ] above ground pool
she thinks it's [ __ ] amazing isn't
that what you guys said hey [ __ ] you
dude punches kind of face dude [ __ ] you
man they [ __ ] you man it was cool i
liked it it was cool i feel super mixed
about this because at the one hand i'm
like ah like if i'm dead i'm not using
any of that [ __ ] right like i'm not
using that but it's a family member yeah
but at the same time
if i knew someone like like took like if
i was like paid for someone to get my
mom cremated or whatever they [ __ ]
took that [ __ ] and sold it somewhere and
then it's getting dissected and no one
said yes to that i'm like that does rub
me a little bit the wrong way what
pisses me off is i didn't get no cut
that also too yeah that's yeah that's
the biggest [ __ ] took my mommy and
give me a cut for me i just feel like no
matter what you're doing you're
desecrating the [ __ ] out of bodies yeah
so like it just all reads the same to me
yeah yeah like you mix them up with a
bunch of other benefits you're like
parents or grandparents what if it was
like nicki lager and then she died and
you like needed to like go bury her well
you would want her ashes wouldn't you
yeah okay you guys can reach me with
nikki but everybody else i don't really
want that's what i mean though is it
somebody that you actually care about
you got to find the person she cares
you're my hot sister
um dude i mean those are going in my
pocket
he's like no this is not leaving the
house i'll tell you that i'm like hey i
take a bag to go
i will say it's [ __ ] up
obviously the uh selling of family stuff
but i gotta admit
if you're [ __ ] in charge of cremating
people and then like you know you just
find some gold teeth and [ __ ] like that
that that seems like a game but are they
but if i'm if i'm the just
discerning cremator cremating uh
customer am i like checking that [ __ ]
later i'm like oh there's you won't
[ __ ] know that's true like you're
going to a [ __ ] funeral and you're
like dad and you [ __ ] open up his
mouth and you're all checking all right
he's got his gold teeth
gotta yeah you gotta say that so you
gotta put that on like invoice claim
beforehand you know don't take it it's
like when you go take your card to get
worked on and you like and then they
like make the note and be like okay
there was like a like a radio on here
and there was a like thing in the glove
compartment yeah i bet people do this
[ __ ] all the time undertakers all across
the [ __ ] nation are doing this mm-hmm
all the people haven't gotten yet every
job oh yeah like even electricians you
know like when they do demolition jobs
what they'll do is uh like all the
previous cable yeah it's expensive yeah
so per job they can take that and
recycle it and make like a couple g's
that's what crackheads do man yeah movie
theater employees they're going up and
down the aisles at the end of the movies
you think they're not taking that
popcorn one little number
[Laughter]
yeah hell
yeah the wallet keep that wallet a
little bit of cake diet coke
that's mr pig naughty like it's still
cold it's still cold hey this one's
still cold and the other guy's like oh
so cold to the guys like yeah i'm
[ __ ] here drinking it dude get the
[ __ ] out of my face the guy's still here
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you